manhood is ongoing for the suspect who
killed 39 people inside an Istanbul
nightclub on New Year's Eve new cell
phone video shows a clear picture of the
accused gunman he took the selfie video
while he walked through Istanbul the
suspect still has not been named but
we're learning about a series of clues
he left behind Jonathan Vigliotti is in
Istanbul this morning the clearest image
we have of the alleged nightclub
attacker comes from this selfie video
walking the streets of Istanbul it's
unclear when it was taken or how it was
found Turkish media say it was leaked by
investigators last night they raided an
apartment near the airport they were led
to the area by a taxi driver this video
being run by Turkish media reportedly
shows the shooter getting out of a cab
after the attack on Club Rana early
Sunday morning the gunman seen here
exchanging money in Istanbul is still at
large Isis who claimed responsibility
for the attack said he was avenging
turkeys role in Syria's bloody civil war
it's unclear if the gunman was directed
or inspired by the militant group and
ikes his statement said the club was
targeted because it was where quote
Christians celebrate their pagan holiday
about 600 people were inside the club
ringing in the New
an hour later the gunman struck the
venue in just seven minutes he killed 39
people before slipping away in the chaos
heavily armed officers evacuated
clubgoers some with bloodstains on their
clothes these crazy people came in
shooting up William Jacob Rock of
Delaware was among the nearly 70 injured
he was shot in the leg but well enough
to return to the US on Monday police say
the gunman acted alone but at least 14
people have been detained for
questioning for CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti in Istanbul Turkey